un discours d'adieu à la veille d'une
passation de pouvoir inédite puisque le
président sortant n'y assiste pas après
avoir refusé le verdict des urnes
portant joe biden à la tête des états
unis donald trump joue finalement
l'apaisement toujours sans le nommer il
souhaite bonne chance au nouveau
président cette semaine nous inaugurons
une nouvelle administration et prions
pour qu'elle réussisse à assurer la
sécurité la prospérité de l'amérique
nous adressons nos meilleurs voeux et
nous voulons aussi qu'ils aient de la
chance c'est très important dans son
discours donald trump vante son bilan
économique et sa politique étrangère
il s'est également dit fier de ne pas
avoir lancé de nouvelles guerres durant
son mandat il ya quatre ans nous avons
entrepris un grand effort national pour
reconstruire notre pays
renouveler son esprit et redonner
l'allégeance de ce gouvernement à ses
concitoyens je me tiens devant vous
vraiment fier de ce que nous avons
accompli ensemble nous avons fait ce
pourquoi nous sommes venus ici bien plus
encore la diffusion de son message est
intervenue alors que joe biden quitter
son fief du deleware le président élu a
rappelé qu'en 2009 il prêté serment en
tant que vice-président de barack obama
il y à 12 ans j'attendais à la gare de
wilmington qu'un homme noir viennent me
chercher pour aller ensemble à
washington où nous avons prêté serment
en tant que président et vice président
des états unis d'amérique et nous voici
aujourd'hui ma famille et moi sur le
point de retourner à washington pour
retrouver une femme noire d'origine
indienne afin de prêter serment en tant
que président et vice-présidente des
etats-unis
le 46e président des états unis va être
intronisé dans un climat particulier
la pandémie de kovy de 19 a fait quatre
cent mille victimes dans le pays
les américains restent également
traumatisé par l'invasion violente du
capitole qui a fait cinq morts